et maintenant une affaire qui dure
depuis quatre semaines les 48 familles
de squatteurs expulsés de leur logement
à paris et qui campent en plein air en
attendant d'être relogées une quinzaine
de procès propositions se leurrent sont
arrivés sans être réglé leur problème
est désormais donc je dirais pris en
compte reporter eric perrin philippe
turpault camping forcé depuis 25 jours
dans ce soir place de la réunion
48 familles avec 53 enfants attendent un
logement
les repas se prennent sur place grâce à
l'aide de plusieurs organisations
humanitaires mais les conditions de vie
deviennent de plus en plus difficile ça
très très durable au saut j'ai deux
enfants déjà les entrées à broche et
risquée le 2 mai dernier toutes ces
familles sont expulsées d'immeubles
qu'elle occupait sans autorisation
depuis plusieurs mois la mairie la
préfecture considérant que le squat est
illégal refuse alors de les reloger
rires d'usure enfin la semaine dernière
les premières propositions arrivent 15
au total
un seul bail de signer la plupart des
familles n'ont pas encore eu l'occasion
de visiter les logements
seuls cinq d'entre elles se sont rendues
à saint denis où l'on veut les reloger
dans une cité de transit sans eau chaude
ni chauffage
une a répondu non fermement parce qu'on
lui avait proposé un f2 et
il y a six enfants donc c'est trop petit
les deux problèmes qui se posent dans
ces cités c'est cela c'est que les
logements apparemment son quotidien pour
les familles et ses problèmes aussi de
d'hygiène
son difficile d'autant plus que la
population de la cité est hostile à la
réouverture de ses appartements
s'il comptait justement que la cité
allait être dévoyé qui sera logé dans
des conditions normales par des
expulsions sans relogement le mot
d'ordre est répété inlassablement les
squatteurs du 20e réclament des
solutions descente est définitive et que